and if I told you that the vox machine legend
one of the best animated series of the moment.
and that you can find in prime video
is based on real events
come and stay,
I'll tell you
you will see in 2015 a series of voice actors
decided to show it to the world
how good and trying the role was.
I love nothing more and nothing less than dragons and dungeons.
on twitch and boy did they make it they spent 2 years
more than 300 hours
more than 115 sessions and good
in short
to close the cycle
wanted to promote on kickstarter
an animated episode
based on everything they had played in 20 minutes
at a cost of $750000
for they earned more than 11000000 dollars
which translated into 2h seasons
of the vox machina legend
you can already see in prime video
in addition to comics
where we will be able to learn about the origins of the characters.
in summary the legend of vox machina
you can see in prime video
is irreverent
harrowing
it's fun and best of all you get the potato
that is why I highly recommend it